good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Tuesday cannot believe it's only
Tuesday The Bachelor being on Monday
makes the week feel so long I know and I
just want to say I watch The Bachelor
last night fell asleep with a headache
again there is a direct correlation
however I feel as though once The
Bachelor senior citizen Edition comes
around I'll be feeling better okay
Heather McMann put on her story that her
mom needs to be on it and it's such a
good call oh my god such a great she's
perfect for it's perfect for it I love
the idea of the show I don't know why I
led with that this morning that's right
I was we will obviously talk about it
when we recap The Bachelor later as much
as it should be a pivotal episode it
really wasn't a big deal at all I wasn't
entirely sure if I was finding the
episode to be so lackluster
because I'm coming off of a full day
binge of love is blind which is which is
such an elevated version of this show or
it was just a bad episode I and
literally couldn't tell what the
difference was yeah or maybe like every
other episode of this season has been
like fraught with all these like
curveballs and this was like actually a
pretty standard episode except for you
know spoiler alert
Maddie leaving and they're touching
foreheads with Peter for far too long
but she they took the far eater I think
that meant that she left yes he didn't
walk her to the car or anything because
she was just going back to her hotel
room no I think or he's not sure cuz
next week it looks like he's waiting for
her on the hill to give out the Roses
well Oh we'll recap bachelor I'm like so
disinterested I'm like still just
spending my nights looking at love is
blind memes you know I can't wait for
the finale or the finale and they filmed
a reunion and it's just gonna be so much
premium content yeah I can't wait
totally why are you you like it's public
oh is it yeah oh my god okay okay looks
someone I read enters his mind Oh whew
okay I got a DM yesterday from Vanessa
Lachey told me that there was a reunion
and I thought maybe you just like blew
up my spot no I had heard it entosis my
great-granny and she confirmed it great
we should wait but like that's exactly
what we need because yeah it's cool like
to see how everything is up but I want
to know where are they now it's been two
years this is really core break if
they're still together that's the real B
especially knowing that this was filmed
almost two years ago its final episode
that ends two years ago was
not enough of a finale for me no and
it's like clearly before Nick and
Priyanka were even married because Jess
and her friends are talking about it
like you liked when they got together oh
yeah the time stamp on it because I
didn't think of that yeah because now
there's just like a staple in our lives
sort of very much so we'll leave a good
show for you today obviously to live
reading the fest stories that you need
to know before you make I'm taking about
out of your are you trying to get into
the Fast Five I didn't mean to I'm sorry
there's so much to discuss like
yesterday we recorded to get around
episodes so premium I think like I know
we say this every time but I think the
most interesting episodes we've ever
done because we went through every
single toast guest that's ever come on
the show and we talked about like our
experience during the guest segment what
we you know thought my work like what
they were actually like just some fun
facts and I think people really enjoyed
you know this behind-the-scenes special
it was a good episode for me because I
know I was technically there for most of
the guests but my amnesia causes me not
to remember any of them so it was cool
to like take a trip down memory lane but
for the first time remember that these
events occurred in my life yeah and to
see you know where we came from to where
we are now
yeah the reasons why we've had certain
guests son or guess we want to have or
guess we wouldn't have again it's all
very interesting I think it's also
really hard for us to come up with
dynamic episode ideas and I think that
this was like a really unique idea
thanks I think so too
so we'll see you in March that's all the
February episodes they're all up head to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast if you
become a patron now you get access to
like the last 20 episodes so it's just
chock-full of content if you are having
if you're having a boring workday which
I feel like February is kind of a slow
month Fair Work I feel like that about
every month I feel like that except
about like December ya know the summer
is super slow you work on holiday stuff
before you know maybe you're free or
it's like and that's what they're always
saying yeah that's when we're firing in
all cannons yesterday I got home and
like turn my TV on and I was doing a
million things before I got to change
the channel and for some reason oh it
was on CNBC because I'm always watching
shark tank before bed and Mad Money was
on with that crazy guy Kramer yeah it's
such a nuts show but I was actually
learning a lot the Dow you know it
dropped like over a thousand points
yesterday now go
no but it was like a historic drop
yesterday no but it really was I feel as
though it's always a historic drop and
the Dow is nice I don't know how people
work I'm predictive in stocks like it's
so it's like working in a casino well
that sounds like your dream job
yeah but like it just seems so volatile
like I was actually just watching Sex in
the City
the whole series and then I watched both
movies and in the second movie the
second they go to Abu Dhabi yeah he big
comes home and he was like so stress is
like the market dropped 100 points today
and it's like Oh big you're so stressed
yeah and like imagine if your job I
guess you know if your mood depends on
like this market that's just so out of
your control yeah but then it's like so
moody but then it's like the market
makes you so much money so you're just
like a moody rich person but you could
also be a moody poor person if you don't
play your cards right yeah but I think
if you work in the market your business
manbo and you're doing well but that was
my favorite part of the Emily did it out
of interview when she referenced her
husband as her business man Wow yeah and
that she saw that she was a woman like
with a bimbo know who needed some people
need a type of person and that person is
a businessman Bo I honestly everyone
needs a business hambo but not everyone
can get a business man bo also I don't
think everyone needs one I think some
people actually couldn't handle like the
stress of a businessman Bo like honestly
if Ben worked in finance and was like
literally gone for like 7:00 in the
morning until 9:00 at night like I would
be devastated because I'm so bored and
alone I've now been alone for three days
three nights three nights sleeping in my
bed alone I mean me and th EO have never
been closer so I'm happy about that know
that I am but I'm so [ __ ] bored and
you know what like even on a regular
week where it's super boring and Ben and
I are home together like he's in the
living room and I'm in the bedroom
because we watched different stuff and
we're like not even together in our own
house but the feeling of knowing that
like if someone you know barges in and
murders us he gets to go first
I am really comforted by that feeling so
I've been feeling like there's no
separation between me and the murderer
next door you know it's just me well you
do have like a guard job oh please
vo in indicates of an emergency switch
sides so quickly of course he would just
he's more of the love the one you're
with type so if this murder is coming in
with treats like I'm finished yeah
that's all a murderer needs to know like
hey you want a murder Claudia her guard
dog just like it's bad
but he's a beautiful angel and he's
really been adding so much value to the
show you don't want to jinx anything but
like he's everything in the sword also I
couldn't sleep last night because I was
watching tic TOCs before bed as I always
do and you know have you seen that trend
it's like something scary that changed
my life check and like people like
document like crazy things that have
happened to them so this girl used that
um audio and she had the security
footage when she was working in a retail
store but someone who come and came in
and tried to rob it and the foot the
security cameras like right at the desk
and she's sitting at the desk and this
huge dude she's like this young girl
this huge dude comes around that I said
I'm sorry to do this to you and was like
open the register and she [ __ ] ran so
fast around the other side of the desk
out of the door and the the video was so
crazy at when finally I had like 8
million views and it's just like
freaking me out it was a terrible thing
to walk before web oh I'm sorry but she
made it out yes you made it out yes she
was I think it was a boost mobile store
she was really brave but then I couldn't
say that's why I also can't watch SVU
before bad there's a lot of things I
can't watch before bad what else yeah
when I was younger like I wouldn't like
watching Pretty Little Liars before bad
agreed I used to watch how to get away
with murder but then like the spooky
music I just couldn't watch it before
bed so then I stopped watching it
because I don't have any other time to
watch TV bluebloods is like a much more
toned down version of SVU but I usually
won't watch it during the night time
especially if I'm alone but I remember
how to sleep over in like the ninth
grade and we watched an episode of SVU
before bed and happened to be a
particularly scary one where iced tea
and Rashmi Hargitay go undercover in a
woman's prison to see if the guard is
like raping the inmates and there's like
a holdup a nicety gets held up and we're
car tickets left alone in the basement
of the president the rapist guard and
it's so scary and I literally was up at
this girl's house till 6 a.m. like I
couldn't sleep wow that's a really I
know that episode of materially scary
almost as scary is the nanny who was
kept in a cage onto the bed in the
trundle yeah I can't look scary so you
can't go down this road this more no
it's too beautiful of a week even though
I do have a feeling it's gonna be a slow
week because it's only Tuesday but
that's a bachelor effect cuz it makes
your Monday so long I was thinking last
night and how I kind of wish that the
bachelor was on Tuesdays because when
you finish the bachelor you feel so
accomplished it's like two hours for me
like I live Instagram and tweet
sometimes so it really is like a job for
me and then I wake up and it's Tuesday
but if I wake if I woke up after The
Bachelor and it was Wednesday I would
feel like the week is mostly over yeah I
can
but it's not and that's just my pill to
swallow and my cross to bear damn pill
to swallow you know I thought I'd change
it up I've been getting so many targeted
Instagram ads for Jagged Little Pill the
a lot of smaller set Broadway play so I
think that's why the word pill was like
in my brain well I like it I appreciate
it also this week is gonna be crazy
because we might have to go to LA we
definitely be in LA on Friday so we
might go Thursday or myko tomorrow we
have to figure our [ __ ] out but you'll
have a show Thursday Friday Thursday
might be from here Thursday might be in
LA just stay tuned follow us science to
him yeah we'll keep you posted
anyways I guess it's time we actually
have a lot to discuss today so I'm gonna
say it's time for the Fast Five story is
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your mind post
again um in today's episode of the
morning shows I would be devastated I
would be Ramez I would be heartbroken I
would have a case of DRH if they didn't
let you all know that today's episode is
brought to you by the reel reel where
you can own iconic luxury items and an
unreal value with the reel reel the
leading reseller of authenticated luxury
consignment from top designers like
Louis Vuitton Gucci Rolex OTA and
hundreds of more at up to 90 percent off
retail for those of you don't speak
French I was cardiac thank you
translation by lingual show you get shop
and consign women's and men's luxury
fashion and street wear as well as fine
jewelry watches art and home they have
new arrivals coming in daily and every
item undergoes the real reals meticulous
authentication process in fact they
employ over a hundred Brent specialists
gemologist serologist and art curators
from around the globe who inspect
thousands of items each day to ensure
that every item is authenticated
you can shop luxury the sustainable way
so the real real is like the biggest
online consignment store it's the best
we've shopped there for years we both
consign therefore yours a lot of my
designer pieces the Gucci bag that I'm
wearing today
oh my loafers too my boots are from rail
rail today they're vêtements my Gucci
loafers it's just such a great way to
shop and not feel like you're
overspending and then if you do feel
like you've bought too much you can
actually consign and sell your stuff
back with them so you can make space for
new designer items because it's Jackie
said it's an investment they also have
an app that you can download to shop
which is great and you can now visit
some of their retail stores in Soho or
West Hollywood plus save a new location
at 870 Madison Avenue in New York we've
just had such a pleasant experience with
the rail rail and I'm so glad that
they're sponsoring the show and you can
shop in store online or download the app
I like the app just saying and you can
get 20% off select items with the promo
code real 20
percent off is a lot that's the real
real calm promo code real for 20% off
select items the real real code real I
love the real real app the best thing to
do is like if you really want something
save it in feed is get a feed and it
like you'll be able to see when this
search comes up you don't have to keep
researching it every time yeah I have a
search for Graham Allen's in there and
then one above my bed is from the real
real they're very uh they're a hot
ticket item on the real real you got you
gotta be on it you got to act fast when
they post new item but in the second it
was up I bought it you can't hesitate no
you cannot hesitate it was like a it was
like a seven on the daughter poster that
I got for it foreign trawlers Wow in a
frame Wow yeah it was great okay well
first story the Kobe Bryant memorial
celebration of life was yesterday it was
so moving
emotional touching and there were even
just like some moments of of
light-hearted humor yeah and it was
really beautiful Vanessa Bryan spoke
publicly for the first time since the
death of her husband and daughter in
front of 20,000 people celebrities
athletes and fans who crammed into the
Staples Center for the Kobe Bryant
memorial Alicia Keys Christina Aguilera
and Beyonce performed while Shaq and
Michael Jordan were among those to give
emotional tributes in a lighter moment
Jordan tears streaming down his face
acknowledged the Jordan crying meme -
laughs from the crowd yeah that was
really funny I just think the best part
of this memorial was to Beyonce her
performance okay I can't believe she saw
she chose EXO because that's my favorite
song and I love the John Mayer version
too and she did like Abby's favorite
song and she did like a stripped-down
version that honestly sounded like the
John Mayer version and with the choir
and the like little Orchestra it was
spectacular and her vocals and she
looked you know it's hard to dress for
something like that because when you're
like a Beyonce like you look amazing
wherever you go but you can't look like
too good and she just was like owning it
in a power suit and I thought she looked
phenomenal I thought this her vocals
were amazing I thought the song
selection was great and what really is
interesting is that song XO is in the
first verse there's a line and I'm
crashing into you and she said and I'm
laughing into you yeah which was just
like a thoughtful I wouldn't have
thought anything like of the word
crashing but obviously this is not the
time yeah it was just I thought she was
sensational like I have sensational she
opened the memorial and just like the
the right note
and figuratively and she also sang halo
which has a perfect song to sing um she
she was perfect yeah like I felt like a
highlight for me
yeah and that was a highlight in like my
relationship with Beyonce to like I I
love Beyonce and I don't feel like I'm
like her number-one fan but like last
night I was like I think honestly every
day I'm getting closer to yeah and it
was just really cool how like she's in
this room full of like the nothing it
was about this but as she was just in
this room it's like huge celebrities
athletes and it's like she's just like
owning all of them you know anything
like she's just she's the center of the
universe honestly and that's what it
felt like when she was performing yeah
it was it was truly moving and beautiful
as well as the speeches Vanessa spoke
for the first time publicly they stepped
out for the first time publicly and she
was just so strong I know and you know I
first of all like I've actually given a
eulogy and it's [ __ ] hard and like to
not just cry the whole time it's like
one of the hardest things and she kept
it together flawlessly like I think
there was maybe one or two moments where
she understandably broke down but it's
really hard and at the end of the day
like a eulogy like you have to just get
through it and I thought she did it
really gracefully yeah she was really
strong and it was so touching
Shaq spoke as well and Michael Jordan
they they it was so emotional but also
full of light-hearted humor and yeah
perfect note I just thought the whole
thing was so well executed obviously
like the family and the fans just got so
much out of it and I think it was a
really great memorial yeah and I think
in moments like that that type of
light-hearted humor is obviously really
necessary and well I don't think it
should be like the focal point and the
whole thing should be hysterical I think
that jokes like that are so important
like I feel like I'm always the person
to like make the joke that's like not
inappropriate but that just brings like
a little levity to like an otherwise
heavy situation yes and it was really a
celebration of life yeah clearly like he
was a jokester and it really came
through yeah and like I didn't know Kobe
personally be like after watching it I'm
like I read best friends like I know
everything about him yeah it was really
beautifully done honestly all the
proceeds went to his foundation for the
tickets and it's really nice to see like
celebrity is not only like posting an
Instagram but then like showing up you
know like JLo and a-rod were there at
Alicia Keys Chris like people in Kanye
like just swaying waiting every union
love love them it's just cool to see
like people acting you know and like do
and showing up yeah and to be honest
like when you're going through something
so tragic like you just need people
around you yeah and everyone says like
is there anything I could do like yeah
just say like to sit down so 20,000
people yeah it helps yeah also there
were 30 I thought this was so
interesting there were 33 thousand roses
or flowers on the stage because that's
how many points he scored in his career
oh my god that's so many points yeah Wow
Wow okay also Vanessa Bryan has filed a
wrongful death lawsuit after Kobe's
helicopter crash as she should be News
has learned attorneys for Vanessa's have
been in a wrongful death lawsuit against
Island Express helicopters in documents
obtained by e-news attorneys filed a 72
page wrongful death lawsuit in Los
Angeles Superior Court arguing Island
Express agents and employees including
our George sobai in the pile the pilot
of the helicopter who also died in the
crash
had a quote duty to use that degree of
care that an ordinarily careful and
prudent pilot would use under the same
or similar circumstances the lawsuit
accuses the pilot of failing to properly
monitor and assess the weather prior to
takeoff failing to obtain proper weather
data prior to the subject flight failing
to abort the flight when he knew of the
cloudy conditions failing to properly
maintain control of the helicopter in
flight failing to properly avoid natural
obstacles in the flight path failing to
keep a safe distance between the
helicopter and natural obstacles and
among other accusations failing to
properly and safely operate the
helicopter resulting in the crash it's
like so sad because like he died too and
then like everyone's blaming him you
know yeah but it's also like it's on the
company too right to employ ya know and
also to not let anyone fly ya know I
mean obviously they're gonna win and
like in situations like this it's like
whatever they'll get like hypothetically
they got I got a hundred million dollars
out of it it's like it doesn't even help
no it doesn't it doesn't help it's like
irrelevant but at this suit is very
justified because it really was that
error is she's suing on behalf of just
her family or of all the families I'm
imagining behalf of all yet all the
families that has just been doing like
all the right things do you know what I
mean
not that there's anything wrong you
could do but it's every time she speaks
up or like post on Instagram I just find
it I have so much respect for everything
that she's saying and like I just agree
with everything that she's doing and
it's really hard when like you're just
going through like the grieving process
and that's all you want to focus on but
you have to plan a memorial and you have
to do all these things and you have to
file a lawsuit like you just don't want
to be thinking about that you just want
to spend time grieving and I just feel
like she's really handling everything
with such elegance and grace and I have
the utmost respect for her me too love
her that was really beautiful touching
very well done you haven't watched it
there are great clips on YouTube yeah I
didn't want you to feel I literally saw
the whole thing
in clips on Twitter yeah Zach was
watching it last night and then this
morning I watched highlights on what
channel was it on well for me it was
just on YouTube the whole thing oh very
cool okay um in a little bit of justice
being served news Harvey Weinstein the
verdict has come down for Harvey
Weinstein he has been found guilty of
two of the five charges against him on
Monday and he's also been admitted to
the hospital that's where the true
justice is because honestly I read an
article explaining all the charges and
he was only charged found guilty of like
the two lesser yeah charges he was found
guilty on two counts of rape in the
third degree and criminal sexual act in
the first degree
however the sentencing will happen on
March 11th but experts are saying that
these charges could carry a sentence of
like between five and twenty nine years
in prison right is an old man and an ill
one which he's really been playing up if
you're super sick I've seen on SVU and
stuff like if you're like ninety or
something you murdered someone but you
have like cancer they won't let make you
go to jail yeah but um I don't think
anyone is having mercy but the other
charges that he was charged with were
bigger sentences and like worse crimes
so technically I don't think that this
was like a huge victory but at least
it's not enough it's a victory that's
going to jail a good victory and I feel
like they're just related back to like
Kevin Spacey who were dropped against
him and so I think given the fact that
it's not a sure thing that someone would
be convicted like this is a victory yeah
and to me it's like Harvey Weinstein is
like the the go-to guy when you think of
like men taking advantage of women women
and so if even he's not going to get
found guilt
on all of his charges like who is yeah
it would just be so demoralizing yeah he
deserves to be in prison and he is going
to prison and to be honest I really feel
like him being found guilty in any way
I'm going to prison for however many
years is gonna have an impact on like
other [ __ ] losers in Hollywood who
think that they can like use their
casting couch like they don't want to go
to jail I think that this will have like
a real implication on just scaring
people into doing the right thing or
just into calming the [ __ ] down yeah so
that's great I think I think it's great
all around the time's up organization
but this hasn't really fast because we
were just during my Jerry selection with
Gigi Hadid yeah but you know what I
think you think it's been like at least
a month you know they're there every day
it's just crazy like I thought it would
totally like to talk about like trials -
yeah and now sentencing is March 11th
that's like less than a month away
mm-hmm I bet it'll be postponed because
I'd be in the hospital for like his bad
back or something I don't understand why
sentencing can't be like tomorrow you
know why doesn't it happen okay you're
found guilty
here's your sentence well because the
jury decides the verdict the judge
decides the sentencing so the judge
doesn't know I mean this is just like me
assuming why don't they take like an
hour recess or the job she can figure it
out yeah I don't know I think he
probably look he or she looks at other
factors yeah it just seems like a really
long time like a waste of taxpayer
resources to like call another day in
court yeah you know mm-hmm the time SVU
they say you're guilty and I sentence
you to five days in prison like well I
think it's just because it's a the show
yeah guys the time some organization
released a statement saying this trial
and the jury's decision today marks a
new era of justice not just for the
silence breakers who spoke out at great
personal risk but for all survivors of
harassment abuse and assault at work
agreed agreed
what who justice is served the words of
man binds bring in the dancing lobsters
will be how much time he gets if he gets
like two years like I'll seriously
annoyed the minimum has to be fires yeah
because that's for one count and he had
like three counts yeah one of the counts
is five years the other count holds 24
years Wow so minimum five I think do you
think he'll go to one of those like
Felicity Huffman prisons probably but
it's still prison no because he
committed sexual crimes and she
committed
financial crimes I do think that there
different yeah what do they call it blue
collar crime murder white-collar crime
no murder I don't know I don't want
white-collar crime that was like the in
white wolf of Wall Street when he was
like oh that was blue collar no no no I
don't know yeah
okay let's take a quick break before the
next story she let the sirens pass hope
everyone's okay
sorry about that let's jump into the
third story murder is a blue-collar
crying murders the blue-collar okay um
Oh is there another story coming up
there is another story coming up but I
just would love to know who is bringing
us this story because we couldn't do it
without them do you want to guess oh
okay this is actually a let's do
charades okay hold on
well charades like with words because
this is a middle most just okay um two
words one syllable in a first word box
close squares yes yes oh my god we are
still good at this game
this segment is brought to you by
Squarespace they've got it all domains
web sites online stores oh my god oh my
god theater started so that oh my god
actually smells like it might be sick we
should make a Squarespace store to
bottle up the Theo's farts and smell
doesn't perfume so that people know what
we're smelling when we're complaining
you guys they're sickening honestly it
was really nice to him to get off my
chair and laid out on the floor to fart
United mean yeah okay from websites and
online stores to marketing tools and
analytics Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business say more
and sell more with their new feature of
email campaigns you can stand out in any
inbox and swith square peace Squarespace
email campaigns their all-in-one
platform makes it easy to unify your
brand voice from your homepage to your
emails you can have consistent content
from your website to your email with
powerful editing tools to make it your
own
they've customizable layouts for any
message and mobile editing so you can
send an email to your customers anywhere
any time things you can do with
Squarespace are create a beautiful
website you can turn your cool idea into
a new website showcase your work
bloggers published content sell products
and services of all kinds or promote
your business and you can announce any
upcoming event or special project on
your domain with a beautiful template
created by world-class designers they
have powerful ecommerce functionality
that lets you sell anything it's free
and secure to hosts they have built-in
search engine optimization we are using
Squarespace you should be using
Squarespace whether you're a blogger a
writer or a photographer makeup artist
whatever head to Squarespace comm slash
toast for a free trial when you're ready
to launch use the offer code toast to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain so that
squarespace.com slash toasts for a free
trial and then when you're ready to
launch your website use the offer code
toast to see
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain love it
sign on start a website okay next a Pete
Davidson has sitting down for an all
encompassing interview with Charlemagne
the god who's the greatest interviewer
of our generation
totally and he's talking about at all
including the moment he knew that his
engagement with Ari was over well get to
it but I just want to talk about
Charlemagne for a minute because I feel
like um he gets it out of people do you
know what I mean yeah I think a lot of
people in the industry like really
respect him and won't normally do
interviews but because they're like
friendly with him they sit down with him
and he's so he's so good at his job yeah
but I feel like also when they're ready
to tell all they want to talk to him
right because they feel comfortable but
like I never actually like sought out to
listen to Breakfast Club but I would say
9 out of 10 of the times I get into an
uber in the morning the uber driver is
listening to Breakfast Club so I get my
like Breakfast Club picks and I totally
get like the stand they have like cult
following ya know it's a great show Pete
Davidson had a feeling his engagement to
ariana grande would end when Mac Miller
died quote I totally got it she would
even tell you this I was like listen I
get it do whatever you've got to do I'll
be here I think I said I'll be here
until you don't want me to be here the
star figured their relationship wouldn't
withstand the tragedy but defended
grande saying her morning was 100%
genuine quote I pretty much knew it was
it was around over after that that was
really horrible and I can't imagine what
that [ __ ] is like all I do know is that
she really loved the [ __ ] out of him and
she wasn't putting on a show or anything
that was [ __ ] up prayers to his family
and all of his friends yeah you know
what like that was like such a bad
situation for literally everyone
involved like Pete Davidson was really
never gonna be the man for ariana grande
because she was grieving the whole time
and honestly she was probably not ready
to be in a relationship for Ari it was
like the worst situation ever cuz she
lost loved him for life and for macmost
family was like the worst situation so
no one could win and it's interesting to
see his perspective now being out of the
situation cuz we all thought that when
it was happening yeah and we all just
assumed that was why but it's it's
always nice to you know finally know
what happened in a celebrity
relationship and it's just what we
thought it was so it's just a crazy like
time I like that time and but when it
was happening we knew it was crazy it
was the best of times I mean I do think
this current era is also crazy that one
where ariana is dating Jim Carrey
probably totally with Jim
I I can't see it any other way who
talked about their club yes so on Friday
after the toast she posted a photo black
and white of her and Jim because they're
working on his show together which is
like a Showtime like kids show yeah but
like she doesn't know that there's like
a podcast out there who like knows that
they're you know have a romantic
relationship allegedly also did you see
the Jimmy Fallon or some like interview
with ariana grande from the last five
years where they were talking about
celebrity crushes and they it's like
right on a whiteboard who their
celebrity crushes they thought the other
person's worth and hers was Jim Carrey
you guys like it's it's all there it's
but I know it's 100 percent true
allegedly I really believe that
allegedly it is true no it is 100
percent probably true hopefully it is
allegedly 100 percent true I've no doubt
in my mind that it's may be true no like
I would love for this to be I want
gently true you know I mean I'm there's
something not a shadow of a doubt that
this is 100 percent most likely true
yeah I just I really I'm so I want the
best for both of them did you see the
clip of their work together on his show
I heard you watching it that's so
[ __ ] strange yeah and not that Ariana
didn't do a good job I just think maybe
I don't understand the show because it
was like a weird community theater
musical I just didn't understand and I
understand that there are people out
there who are like no they're not
together they're just physically
together right now because she's cameo
on his show but no I'm saying yes that's
how they got together she finally met
her celebrity crush Jim Carrey met
ariana grande and she was down for him
and he's obviously gonna be down for her
and to be on they actually have a lot in
common she has a really crazy sense of
humor he is so funny they've both been
through personal tragedy yes in their
relationship dark and I think that this
is a match and being the aged blind
Queen that I am I don't see a problem
here I don't see a problem either but I
just don't think that it's a normal
reaction for people to be like they're
just working to get there
why the [ __ ] would ariana grande be
going on this weird-ass show if it
weren't for because Jim Carrey's one of
her heroes yeah if it weren't for her
affection for Jim Carrey there's not
just a normal press stop on the Orianna
grande press tour there's the difference
between like idolizing someone in their
work and then being in a romantic
relationship with them and I think a lot
of people can't see how they could ever
be in a relationship but like I
completely see it I think this will be
one of those relationships that never
goes public and the quietly end
in like a few months and we'll never get
confirmation and I'm okay with that
Ariana Grande it's just like a little
freaky like you know anything that to me
like Jim Carrey and Pete Davidson are
this similar a cut from the same cloth
just you know of a different era but I
do think that like she likes an older
man it's nice to see that both Pete
Davidson Legend grande like have a type
like he dated like a millionaire grandes
after her and she did is dating another
Pete Davidson I actually think he dated
like a million of the same girl but yeah
she was different
they were different yeah and by the way
of that crazy time Justin Bieber and
Haley Bieber are still together
Nicki and Priyanka so that was like a
crazy month period where all these young
people in Hollywood were getting married
and we thought it was like a cult
yeah I honestly I love to see it them
and honestly the cult that I think it
was was just Christianity which is not a
cult it's just I think it was the cult
was love yeah my favorite cult me too
okay next up it's really up there with
nexium looser and looser called oh yeah
that's like the world of cold oh yeah
the totsuzen ice-cold but yeah they were
like the biggest wannabe is you know
they just like Brad you people because
they thought that's what cults did no
it's about the camaraderie March yeah
head over to shop mourn HS calm in
latest streaming news netflix rolls out
a top 10 feature to help show what
people are actually watching I love this
Netflix is trying to make it easier for
subscribers to keep up with what people
around the country are watching by
introducing a top 10 road to its home
page a new blog post from the company
published today notes that the top 10
row will be updated every day with the
most popular titles within a subscribers
country like that and the position of
the row will also change depending on
how relevant the shows and movies in the
list are to their interests Netflix also
show notes that subscribers can get in
even better sense of what's trending by
clicking on the individual movies and TV
show tabs to get top 10 lists for each
respective category I love this yeah I
mean we have been reporting on new
updates for Netflix like they got rid of
their auto play for the trailers but
when are they can be implemented mine
still has that oh really
yours I use in I use an Amazon fire sick
I feel I don't know if mine still has it
I have my own Netflix problems where on
my TV in my bedroom I like we have a
family account and I can't watch on my
profile I have to watch on snitches
snitches there any watch love is by me
that's so weird because I was on Netflix
yesterday like doing some research on
something right now I'm
my computer and I was watching on yours
no and Zach watches like on my profile
in the living room it's just in my TV so
I'm not in a position to like maybe Zach
watching on your profile you can't watch
on the profile at the same time not
sometimes the same time it's just always
it's so more than annoying it's really
annoying because now I'm not like
building up like my personal algorithm
and right niche is probably like I never
watched this has your date oh she's your
date yeah it's frustrating yeah but i
watch netflix on my TV to different tvs
and my ipad and sometimes my computer
and I feel like I get a different
version of Netflix everywhere so all
these updates like are irrelevant I
don't think I'm gonna get I still have
autoplay it's so [ __ ] annoying on my
Amazon fire stick and I don't even know
if I'm gonna get the top 10 but I by the
way I love this idea I love this idea
and by the way just in case you were
curious the top six in the circle for
sure in the u.s. today
one is to all the boys I love before -
Wow - is the stranger three is lock and
key for is fall from grace five is sex
education six is love is blind but I
think that love is - just at the
beginning of like it's popping off yeah
I mean I literally spent the entire day
watching love is blind means like it's
literally the best show and you know who
started it is Olivia and dr. Shapiro and
like their take on it is so funny Oh
Shapiro like doesn't get it he's never
watched a bachelor he's like these
people are getting engaged he just
doesn't believe it and I'm like you just
you have to suspend disbelief for a
while and just like dive in headfirst
because his take is so funny on it yeah
I'm so excited for the next episode
Thursday I'm just I can't wait did
anyone find out what time the episode
drops midnight I believe on Wednesday so
you don't watch it I don't think so yeah
I want to enjoy it I mean I don't want
to rush to watch it and especially for
taking up light on Thursday then bowling
totally our fifth and final story is an
in memoriam because Catherine Johnson
the brilliant NASA mathematician who was
credited with helping the u.s. reach the
moon and get home safely has died at 101
and she's the subjects yeah I never saw
him figure oh my god I know it's like a
movie that I actually realizing oh good
you of it you would love it because it's
history but it's also just like it's
it's so cute I just love to watch it and
taraji is amazing and Jenelle is amazing
and everyone's amazing I know I need to
see it Johnson lived the majority of her
life in relative obscurity despite being
one of a handful of african-american win
who did some of the most crucial work at
NASA during the space race in the 1960s
she received more recognition in her
later years culminating with her
portrayal by taraji P Henson in the
movie hidden figures Johnson she was
known to play down her her role in the
Apollo 11 mission one saying quote I'm
as good as anybody but no better not
true but she's everything when we were
at the TPG awards and they had the two
daughters of one of the people from was
that their minds yeah oh god we met
they're her daughters at the TPG Awards
they were there like on behalf of their
mom and they were so cool and like funny
and nice and I didn't realize the
connection until right now that that's
the same person yeah
she's so incredible the movies
incredible and it just shows like this
story is amazing and her legacy will not
be forgotten okay it's very sad but like
also 100 and 101 like goals incredible
yeah
should we recap The Bachelor even though
it was literally so painful it's gonna
be painful for me to like relive it I
know I also watched the episode like
literally at 40% because I was playing
balls on my phone yeah what was I doing
on my phone not much but you can get
distracted by anything it's so easy so
you know very appropriately this segment
of The Bachelor recap is brought to you
by thrive market you know Bachelor
nation's favorite market
okay so thrive market is everything you
need it really is I love thrive market I
know I actually order from them all the
time and they now have stuff maybe they
always have but they did stuff for Theo
that I love yeah it has all like it's an
organic marketplace they have everything
from snacks food I even get some
essential oils from thrive market it is
everything of the sort or is it not it
is it's an online membership based
market on a mission to take healthy
living to an easy and affordable place
for everyone on the guaranteed savings
member only prices so you can get 25 to
50% off traditional retail prices plus
they only sell the highest quality
healthy and sustainable products you can
buy thousands of wholesome food home and
beauty products curated just for their
members I didn't get everything you need
from organic and non-gmo food clean
Beauty save supplements non-toxic home
ethical meat products sustainable
seafood clean wine and more it's healthy
living without the hassle where you can
shop from easily buy you can shop by 70
plus diets and values like keto which is
perfect for them
paleo gluten-free vegan non-gmo
Fairtrade certified bpa-free and tons
more get the app skip the store and the
lines it's good for you and the planet
because orders of $49 and where are
shipped for free and delivered with fast
carbon neutral shipping from their zero
waste warehouse you join thrive market
as they give through thrive gives their
one for one membership matching program
every paid membership sponsor is a free
one for a low-income family go to thrive
market.com slash toast to give thrive
market a try you can choose the
membership model that best fits your
lifestyle they have one month three
month and twelve month options check out
or go to its arrived market.com slash
toast to get $20 off today we love that
you can choose your membership term
because for us we both went with the
12-month membership because it only
comes down to $5 a month so if you're
not sure about the red market and you're
not sure if it's the right fit for you
you can easily give it a try for sure or
short a period of time like three months
thrive market membership is risk free
you could take the first 30 days to
determine if thrive market is right for
you
if it's not just cancel within 30 days
and get a full refund but make sure to
go to thrive market calm / toast to give
thrive market a try that's thrive market
calm / toast for up to 20 dollars off
today sign on thrive amazing fantasy
suites we got three girls left in
Victoria Madison and Hannah and Madison
at the end of it at the beginning of the
episode gives Peter
she was very vague but it was not an
ultimatum it was really a poorly worded
but she should have let him know
anything else I mean I'm she should have
told him why she felt so strong okay so
I wasn't sure if I miss something but
I'm like did this [ __ ] not tell him
that she was a virgin and you know what
it's like it's really frustrating
because all this could have been avoided
because now like obviously Pleader has
been intimate with someone whatever that
means either he had sex or did
everything but yeah it was weirdness
where he didn't we didn't get footage of
Hannah em in the morning but we got
Victoria I don't think he had sex with
Hannah and me neither they did the
Titanic hand I do think he had sex with
Victoria it's literally the only reason
he bites her why he would keep her yeah
because it's not like the emotional
connection has been so stellar
yeah um but I think producers it's like
they don't want the show to be
successful because if they did they
would have had Madison's date first
where she laid it all around the tapes
you got laughs and then Peter would know
how serious it was and it
not just because she can't fathom her
husband having slept with a woman 60s
before that's the show but being someone
who's saving herself for marriage like
that makes it a mistakes much higher and
a much bigger deal if he just goes and
sleeps with someone yeah she was [ __ ]
from the very beginning like the fact
that first of all they were all in the
room together was obviously very
intentional because that's never
happened before at this point after
hometowns everyone has their own room
and they don't see each other ever again
right everything that's good yeah
everything that's going on that's going
wrong with the show is really the
producers fault it's a little Peters
fault too Oh I mean of course but like
because by this producers keep putting
him in situations where he that he can't
handle nobody he also was now back like
in a corner if Madison is really his
wife and he didn't yes she tried to tell
him at the rose ceremony but I don't
think she did a good job conveying how
serious it was also do you feel like she
should have told him earlier like it she
was saving herself yeah I think that she
I mean she it's up to her to tell him
whenever she feels comfortable but I do
think that that is a very big part of
her especially in a relationship and I
think their relationship would have
benefitted from him knowing sooner and
also I think he would have understood
why why it was such a big deal for him
to not sleep with someone if he knew
that about her I totally respect her and
don't think she's being unreasonable but
I just do think she handled it poorly I
think to wait so long to tell him that
you're a virgin and then not even tell
him in that first conversation and then
saying that the date I just think like
you can't expect him to do the right
thing when you are handling it so poorly
mm-hmm
but at this point he probably knows
who's winning like of course they have
to say I'm in love with three women but
he knows so if it's Madison don't [ __ ]
anyone else and if it's not Madison cut
everyone loose like I just I know and if
it's not Madison then continue to play
this game and pretend to be upset that
Madison is leaving and and then choose
someone else I think that's fine but I
think we all believe because how could
it be Victoria or Hanna and we all
believe that Madison is who he wants to
end up with yeah unless it's not unless
it's not but I think that at this point
she's clearly the winner the mom is like
go get her cuz the mom has met her bring
us back to her the mom is so dramatic I
think it's obvious that she is the
front-runner right I thought so but me
not people are really upset with her
like giving it saying that she's giving
local p vy but like she knows what she
signed up for I feel like I've seen she
knows what she signed up for um but you
know what I've also heard like we were
just talking about this on the episode
up for the patreon because when Raiden
came on the show she told us that her
and Nick did not have sex which means
that he didn't have sex with her we know
he didn't have sex with Rachel he only
had sex with the girl that he was the
winner who was the winner so it's not so
crazy to be like if you know I'm the
winner please don't sleep with anyone
else and we have heard I don't know if
it's been in like conversations with
people who were friends with who have
won the show but it has thrown a wrench
into the relationship when you leave the
show knowing that the your fiancee slept
with a runner-up I'm like almost 100
percent sure Ben Higgins had sex with
Jojo and Lauren but he didn't have sex
with Kayla yes so obviously like he knew
Kayla wasn't it but I think he was
genuinely conflicted I think he didn't
know the morning he woke up who he was
gonna choose oh no I think I think he
totally knew I think I know from I don't
told you lecture that he loved her wait
Nick what's his [ __ ] Peters telling
everyone oh by the way because now
that's a thing but yeah before that they
weren't allowed to say to me he was Ben
was never in love with Jojo he told Jojo
he loved her because he had already told
Lauren and then if he didn't say to Jojo
what's the show we know Lauren went oh I
totally thought that like even to this
day he's still in love with Jojo no I
think he like really liked her and his
curious as to where it would've gotten
totally [ __ ] her yes and that's why
I'm Ben and Lauren happily ever after
they had brunch with Jourdan and Jojo it
was like so weird right yeah well I
pulled out my phone because I thought
that really interestingly Dave Portnoy
had a great take on the entire situation
and I didn't expect to agree with him he
said switching gears I don't know
anybody can defend Peter here if he
really came to find his wife and thinks
that it's Madison she gives you an
ultimatum you don't [ __ ] other girls
it's pretty simple if you came on to
[ __ ] other girls then you [ __ ] them
but if you make it to the final three
and you're really here to meet a husband
it's a fair thing to ask and there's no
way he doesn't know who he's picking at
this point he puts X above her end of
story that's not the guy she wants and
to be honest like Hannah and literally
being so [ __ ] desperate like you know
what I understand like I just want you
to know like whatever you have to do
this week to figure out like your wife
is not going to tell you to go [ __ ]
other chicks like your wife and the
woman that you're gonna spend your life
with is like her has a problem with you
sleeping with two other women
two nights concent consecutively before
hanging out with you
yes Peter chose sex over Madison and it
goes back to what we said last
where's Peter is not the right guy for
Madison he's not he's he's not like
wholesome and so as much as I want her
to win and be happy at the end of the
day I don't think that they're
compatible no I actually think here's a
lot in common with Victoria yeah okay so
say Madison's leaving which she should I
really think she should it's important
to her and it's sure it's like these are
worst and it's it's painful for her to
you know you know and even what she said
about like not seeing him kiss other
women like that to compromise that she's
made and she understands the position
that she's in but this is where she
draws the line and you know what like
it's a it's a fair line agreed and you
know what I think I was thinking I'm
like just go home let's make your point
like maybe he'll come back and chase you
but they're in [ __ ] Australia that's
like a 24-hour flight back home to
Alabama so it's not so easy if they were
in California like it would be a less of
a big deal for her to just pick up and
go so I think that I think she actually
stays in Australia but maybe leaves the
show temporarily just because she can't
[ __ ] go all the way back if she's not
a hundred percent sure that she wants to
go home yes but um even with like Cassie
and Colton Cassie went home they stopped
filming the show and then like we see
what happened after her the final race
except there was this show ended and
Peter could end the show flee one if he
wanted to he could jump a fence for
Madison if he wanted to but I think
producers knowing all of this they
should have had Madison's one-on-one
date first and then he knows the stakes
does he sleep with someone else and this
is war and then if he gives her a rose
and then it's two of two people two
girls and one Peter Peter has to let her
know if he slept with someone and then
that's more realistic yet Peter didn't
handle it well but to be honest him
having her debut last and then finding
out only after the facts Betty probably
slept with Victoria only after the fact
that she's a virgin he was really not
set up to do the right thing like he
couldn't like you know any mean I just
don't think it was fair for him to have
gone into the hometown dates without
knowing everything yeah but I also think
that the lead I guess Hannah brown we
know she's up with Peter and she
probably slept with Jed but I feel like
tip like a lot of times the lead really
does only sleep with one person yeah but
it's just not made public because they
want the show to cystine just seem like
it's still technically a competition but
Madison now bringing this up is forcing
us to have the conversation that they
never have yeah because like Nick we
know that he didn't [ __ ] Rachel we know
that he didn't have sex with Raven so we
we we know
that now but in the moment we thought
member Raven was like running on me like
I thought yeah I got even organized I'm
like yeah but that's because they needed
us to think it was affair like that
Raven was just as capable of winning as
Vanessa right and so if Madison hadn't
brought this up we would have still been
thinking like oh he probably had sex
with all them I wonder who's gonna win
but now Madison making it a conversation
and bringing this issue to light we are
now forced to think who we did and
didn't have sex with and I don't think
he [ __ ] Anna Ann I think he definitely
had sex with Victoria yeah but he also
said intimate he didn't say have sex so
it might just like [ __ ] yeah but it's
like if you're not having sex but you're
spending the night together like what is
you doing well it's the first time
you're talking off camera maybe you're
saying things that like Oh telling them
about yourself something that you don't
feel comfortable sharing on camera you
can also just act differently when
you're not pretending to eat a fake meal
yeah you're just like actually being a
couple another interesting thing that I
thought was interesting is that Hannah
Ann um I don't think she had sex with
Peter and then when she gets back to the
house and finds out from Madison that
she like had a conversation with Peter I
think she gets even more mad at Madison
because I think she thinks Madison's the
reason that she didn't get to have sex
with Peter yeah but when I just think
she did have sex with Peter because
she's not the one but soon she'll
probably find out that he was intimate
with Victoria yeah and then she'll
realize it wasn't Madison at all but if
he's not intimate with Victoria like
what was the point in all this they have
absolutely no chemistry but I think he's
just really physically attracted to her
because she's so pretty
yeah and someone actually told me that I
looked like her and I was like a whole
threaten the test about I sort of see it
I sort of see it like big eye and she's
like it was a little bit of weight but
I'm Ben yeah well she's kind of growing
on me like I just she's growing on me
too she's because I don't know why I
think she's compatible with Peter and
I'm only watching the show and like
seeing every end like yeah it's annoying
I can't deal with when she like backs
down from confrontation and gets up and
cries but it's there's obviously
something that he likes about her more
than just physically because I think he
had a really into like a big physical
connection with some other girls member
him and Sydney were literally like oh
yeah sex in that pool yeah so if he
really was just keeping everyone to [ __ ]
them like I don't know that Victoria is
the one he was most physically attracted
I just can't read him at all and it's
really frustrating to like watch a
Bachelor have either no chemistry with
everyone or tons of chemistry because he
treats them all equal he's just like
being an actor yeah I feel like I could
always tell when like a girl really
likes a guy or The Bachelor really is
crazy about one garlic wee
nunik like loved Vanessa I just find it
so frustrating because I cannot read him
whatsoever
yeah and also they show the preview for
like what's coming up but they didn't
put that part in again we're Chris
Harrison says to Peter like we just
found this out like where it looks like
he's about to her pose and Chris
Harrison has some team like it looks
like how to be shows up or I don't know
they found something out about the
person maybe a girl a boyfriend back
home and I just need them to know like
there's no way you can cut that out like
yeah wait til next one I will literally
go down to ABC like Erin Brockovich
style and get that footage next week on
Monday is the rose ceremony and whatever
happens after that
and then Tuesdays women tell all and
then after that it's the finale so we
only have two more well two more weeks
three more episodes I just can't wait
for the see over like I know t see that
Kelly wasn't invited to women tell all
so I saw that Kelly wasn't in LA and
then I saw that she was I know but she
like we responded to some of these
message saying that she wasn't invited
to women tellin multiple toasters reach
out to her and the toasters put it in
the snatchler nation group saying that
she said she wasn't invited to women
tell all but then the next day she flew
to LA and was like with all the girls at
Nobu Malibu or somewhere in Malibu
interesting so I think that she can't
not be there no unless she's in a
relationship already that's unless she's
in talks to be the Bachelorette or
something she yeah and they would give
her a really good at it and make you
fall in love with her now they're making
it so obvious like if she's not there
and she's a very important character yes
maybe they don't want to have to answer
for why they edited her so poorly
yeah but they would just even if they
had even if someone were table they had
a whole conversation then we just cut it
out I wouldn't air it yeah I love Kelly
and she looked sickening in her
Instagram stories from LA yeah I'm
obsessed with her me too
she is good Bachelorette guide vibes
surreal it's just been such a painful
season like I'm I I took a break and I
was like loving the break and now I feel
annoyed that like this is what I went
back in with like full steam ahead
because it was just a waste of my
[ __ ] time
I don't think Peter ends up with any of
these girls to be honest I can't see it
at all I feel like he might just end up
with Hannah Ann and they have like a you
know in Instagram relationship until
they can't no more yeah maybe that's
what kind of ends moving to LA Oh
shocking mm-hmm shocking stuff I'm so
surprised excited for her yeah I really
like her you know there's nothing wrong
with her
she's just thirsty like and by the way I
am too so I never say that as a bad
thing but she has been very
straightforward and she's just not in
love and so she's saying all these
things and it's like oh so you're lying
she's the type of person who watched one
too many episodes of The Bachelor and
it's just she got it right yes she's
like my Kenna watched one too many
episodes of The Bachelor and she got
it's so wrong so to the fact that she's
nothing I'm the Sauron and she just
tells us that over and over
yeah she's constantly telling us that
yeah okay you guys well that's all we
have for you thank you so much for
joining us on this beautiful Tuesday
morning the morning toast streams live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up leave a
comment I don't know just find sww
youtube.com slash good morning toast
we're also available as a podcast
entrepot custome founds that Spotify
iTunes hit your public radio I hurry to
Cass box all the places so ever you
choose to listen to podcasts find
outside the morning toast subscribe
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much have an amazing
day we'll see you tomorrow Wednesday
with Alexis Neiers